hi there steve kaufman here
this is an unscheduled video
i want to salute moses mccormick who
passed away a couple of days ago
uh when i first saw a tweet indicating
that moses had died i didn't believe it
i thought it maybe was someone else with
the same name
but then it was confirmed
that
moses at the age of 39 passed away
with a
heart attack
it happens sometimes young people have
some kind of heart condition
i was just stunned and saddened to hear
this
moses was an outstanding person
um i
did a video about modus moses 11 years
ago i looked it up and i did one with
moses eight years ago
and
what impresses me with moses is
sort of the range of his interests and
the range of his activities
he was born and grew up in akron
ohio which is the midwest i guess it's
it's not quite the middle of the
continent but
it's not a place where international
travelers go normally or where people do
a lot of traveling uh
and yet he from akron ohio reached out
to 50 languages and cultures
as different as
hmong indonesian chinese cantonese
japanese and asia
and swahili
sudanese arabic somali i don't know what
other languages in africa
in europe georgia and estonian
obviously russian the
the major european languages call them
i'm sure i'm leaving some out but he may
spoke some
native american languages
50 was the total number
so he
living and growing up in this town
was able to not only go out and enrich
himself discover the world that he's
living in in his turns out to be short
period of time on this earth to go out
and find out so much of the world that
he's living in
but in doing that and in his videos and
in his
methodology for learning languages and
in his
leveling up where he goes out and meets
people and speaks speaks to them in
their language
he inspired people so he touched people
not only he went out to touch cultures
around the world and languages for his
own
enrichment but he also shared this
enthusiasm and his learning technology
or techniques with so many people around
the world for whom he was an inspiration
so he is it was an outstanding person
who who crammed so much into his short
tragically short period
on this earth and i think there's a
lesson there for us and that lesson is
it doesn't matter who you are where you
live
you can
learn languages discover more about the
world and you can share that with the
world
and
you know we don't live forever
uh none of us is sure how long we're
gonna live
and so every minute every hour every day
we have to try to do something that is
constructive
enriching for us giving us
allowing us to grow and learn and at the
same time try to reach out and and touch
and help other people as much as we can
because that's what moses did
and i would be
very happy if there were some ideas
about what we could do to honor moses
you know
i looked up on the internet achron has a
very nice library system you know could
there be a moses mccormick
reading room with language books
that we could somehow all contribute
towards or some kind of
presence on the internet or something
that that we could do
those of us who were touched by moses to
to honor him and honor his memory
so i just put that out there i have no
concrete ideas in mind but i'm happy to
get involved and i'm curious to hear
what
ideas others may have in the meantime
moses
rest in peace
you
had a powerful
powerful life and powerful influence on
people around the whole world
your family should be very proud of you